regardez bien c'était le 11 janvier 1991
les travaux commençaient à peine le
vinci n'était alors qu'une maquette et
nous tous nous demandions ce que serait
demain ce fameux centre international de
congrès une seule chose était sûre la
galère des travaux avait bel et bien
commencé
le 27 mars de la même année les
tourangeaux de souche étaient en émoi
démolition spectaculaire du superbe
hôtel 1900 qui faisait langue du
boulevard heurteloup et de la rue
bernard palissy à cette époque-là
souvenez vous peu d'entre nous trouvé
l'idée géniale et quentin bout du
patrimoine disparaît c'est un autre qui
ressort de terre octobre 91 fabuleuse
découverte en plein chantier
les archéologues ressorte du
terrassement des centaines d'objets
gallo romains et de très nombreux
ossements
l'explication quelques siècles plus tôt
le palais des congrès était une décharge
20 91 les fondations sont presque
terminés et le vinci accueille deux
invités de marque
françois 1er le mécène qui donnera dans
quelques jours son nom au grand
auditorium et leonardo davinci le maître
d'oeuvre qui pour quelques minutes
volera la vedette à jean nouvel
pendant deux ans le vinci va donc
grandir et sortira progressivement de
terre on aura tous connus les bouchons
du boulevard heurteloup tous râler
contre les travaux mais le paquebot lui
a fait la sourde oreille et s'est
construit comme il l'avait promis après
fabry 93,9 ainsi fait soudain la grimace
le plafond intérieur du monstre vient de
s'effondrer sur les ouvriers trois
blessés légers
ce sera la grosse galère des deux années
de travaux et le plus mauvais souvenir
aujourd'hui oubliée
enfin comment évoquer vinci sans parler
de son concepteur jean nouvel
l'architecte remettra vendredi à 9h30
précises la clé de son chef-d'oeuvre à
jean royer laventure pourra alors
commencer alors a coûté 700 millions de
francs soit près du double du budget
prévu premier congrès le 25 septembre
bon vent à l'équipage du vaisseau
[Musique]